today on the matt welsh show we'll talk
about the most dangerous conspiracy
theory in america today and it's not the
one the media is freaking out about
it's the conspiracy theory that's
currently fueling riots and anarchy in
the streets
also five headlines including a blm and
antifa speaking of that
protesters in la protesters in la
they're using cars now to chase down
innocent motorists and attack them and
guess who the cops are arresting
then a very special daily cancellation
segment dedicated to a very special
person you're not going to want to miss
that all of that on the way but first
you know these days it's really hard to
find companies with good products
reliable services
but it will also support our values and
work towards doing good things in the
culture for a change
there aren't a lot of companies like
that out there unfortunately but they're
here here's one
that you should know about charity
mobile this is the pro-life phone
company and they're called that because
five percent of your monthly plan price
goes to the pro-life
pro family charity of your choice so you
support the pro-life cause even while
just simply paying your phone bill
but it's not just about the charity it's
also a great service i mean listen to
this new activations and eligible
accounts
get a free cell phone with free
activation and free shipping plus
don't worry about contracts don't worry
about termination fees there's none of
that
and there's no risk with a 30-day
guarantee so here's another part i like
you get live customer service based in
in the usa
so this is a win-win you get a good
service good product
great prices very affordable and you
support the most important cause in our
culture today
the pro-life cause call charity mobile
at 1-877-474-3662 or chat with them
online at charitymobile.com
one other note as we've been telling you
if you're watching on youtube
the show will be this show will soon be
moving over to my personal page
youtube.com
matt walsh that's where this show is
going to live now you can still get it
everywhere else on all the other
platforms but if you want to watch on
youtube then you're going to need to go
to youtube.com
matt walsh plus there's a lot of other
content over there on my channel so
let's take a quick peek at that watch
back then lesbian wasn't about sexuality
a lesbian was just any woman not
laughing at a man
is the joke here that feminists are
hysterical and
oversensitive and constantly imagining
that they're being persecuted when
they're really not if that's a joke it's
a pretty good joke but
i suspect that's not the joke chasing
these papers at 12 13 running around in
these crazy with me and my keys
first okay i i just feel like i could
relate so much to what's being said here
uh let's go back and review some of that
he says
i'mma turnt it up a little more this
time used to dream about getting it
now i got it i don't drive i had a spot
like a varsity
what did you have you buy 20 i'll front
what you buy
i put on drip i believe i can fly
n words know that i'm rich but they know
not to try
this is incredible all right go to
youtube.com matt walsh and uh
subscribe i beg you i plead with you i
beseech you
all right now um let's get into this i'm
a little fuzzy on some of the details
but as far as i understand it the
q anon conspiracy theory alleges that
donald trump is secretly at war with a
global ring of satanic pedophiles
and some shadowy agent who goes by code
name
q is keeping devotees of the theory
abreast of new
new developments uh through anonymous
internet posts
now there is about there's about as much
solid evidence to support this idea as
there is to support the claim made by a
lot of the same people as it happens
that the sandy hook massacre was a hoax
which is to say
there is no evidence as is usually the
case with these sorts of things
those advancing the conspiracy theories
tend to think that
the existence of a certain fact
is itself sufficient proof for the whole
cinematic storyline they've concocted to
explain it
sandy hook truthers point out that
certain web pages memorial sites news
articles etc
were time stamped supposedly for before
the attack occurred
this along with a couple of other random
points of data uh some true and some not
is supposed to be all the evidence
needed that 20 dead children never
actually existed or were paid actors or
whatever
now a more logical explanation of course
and one that doesn't require a whole
frantic succession of
additional unproven assertions is that
time stamps on the internet are
sometimes wrong and there's nothing
terribly
unusual or bizarre about that in the
case of q anon proponents can point to
the existence of global sex traffickers
like jeffrey epstein
and this somehow is supposed to strongly
indicate that all the other claims made
by some random guy posting on 4chan
are reliable this is how conspiracy
theories work they feed on our
credulity and on our very human tendency
to make sense of the world by drawing
false connections assuming motivations
and imagining hoping
that reality is as decipherable and
organized as it seems in hollywood films
these theories are baseless and rather
embarrassing
but the media wants it once wants to
make them into something more than that
we're frequently told that cue acolytes
are a danger to our democracy
that they may turn violent at any moment
yet with extremely rare exception
that simply hasn't happened and there
are no signs that it will start
happening
q anon remains a constant threat to spam
our twitter threads and post wacky memes
other than that there's no reason to
fear them
but there is another popular conspiracy
theory that should perhaps cause
some anxiety among the sane one with
many more adherents vastly greater
influence
amplified by mainstream voices in media
and entertainment
and which has proven to be a real and
catastrophic threat to our physical
safety our system of government
and the future of our democracy on an
intellectual level it's no more credible
than q anon or sandy hook and probably
quite a bit less credible
worst of all this conspiracy theory has
the advantage of not being widely and
properly considered
considered or labeled a conspiracy
theory which only increases its
perceived legitimacy
and causes it to grow and spread like
mold in a flooded basement
i refer to the theory that agents of
white supremacy
within law enforcement and without are
hunting and murdering black people
all across the country that's a
conspiracy theory
it is false after the grand jury
decision was announced on wednesday a
guest on msnbc
ranted against quote state-sponsored
white supremacy and killing of black
people
and claim that you can't go anywhere if
you're black because blacks are being
murdered by racist whites with such
regularity
uh let's listen to that that is why
people are upset
that is why protesters are mad at the
media
because they're tired of these
discussions being teased out in ways
that give justifications
for nothing other than state-sponsored
white supremacy and killing of black
people
it is so infuriating and so maddening
you're not safe anywhere because because
i can't go anywhere nicole
if i go jogging i can end up like a mod
arbor right so as proof
of this extraordinary claim made it
should be remarked by a black man who
says he can't go anywhere and yet is
sitting comfortably on national tv
launching wild accusations against the
very country that protects his right to
do so safely
but the guest jason johnson mentions
three unrelated cases over the course of
two years
in two of the cases atatiana jefferson
and botham gene
the cops responsible were indicted
neither case has any plausible
connection
to racism at all he also mentions ahmad
arbory
whose killers have likewise been charged
this doesn't come anywhere close to
justifying the claim that black people
can't go anywhere for fear of being
executed by state-sponsored
white supremacists and he is of course
completely ignoring the statistical
reality that
blacks are more likely to kill whites
than whites are to kill blacks and that
blacks are not significantly more likely
to be killed during the course of an
arrest than our whites
he has done exactly what conspiracy
theorists always do
taking a few random facts or events
plucking them out of context
disregarding from the outset all
alternative explanations for those facts
making no attempt to view them from a
wider perspective and constructing
around them
a far-reaching narrative that creates
more holes than it fills and requires
more explanation than it provides
that's what conspiracy theorists do now
johnson
may be making claims that are absurd
dangerous stupid and utterly lacking any
factual basis
whatsoever but he's not alone uh going
out on that limb this is this is the
the narrative presented by blm and its
mouthpieces lebron james
says that black people can't leave their
homes because they're being hunted
there's no elected democrat on the
national stage who will publicly
disagree
with any of that and most have made
similar statements
the mainstream liberal media hollywood
the democrat party all have joined with
the delusional
rioter in the street who speaks of a
white supremacist conspiracy to
exterminate innocent black americans
none have offered any evidence of this
conspiracy
they have only random anecdotes all of
which can be easily accounted for
without recourse to imaginary genocides
now unlike q anon this conspiracy theory
has real world consequences
one wacko was motivated by the pizzagate
conspiracy theory to show up to
comet ping pong pizzeria in dc and fire
off three shots hitting no one but
damaging a wall and a door and
maybe a desk or something four years
later this event is still trotted out as
an example of the dangers of far-right
conspiracy mongering
meanwhile hundreds of thousands of
people have been motivated by the
white supremacists are hunting black
people conspiracy theory to torch cop
cars destroy buildings loot vandalize
assault
kill if pizzagate and q anon have
dangerous implications
then the theory promoted by blm is
downright apocalyptic
in its consequences it is intended to be
those who propagate it are actively
trying to destroy the public's faith in
our institutions
one's faith in our institutions will
naturally tend to waiver if one
seriously believes that
they're run by genocidal white
supremacists and now the calls for the
abolition of police can be heard even
from mainstream voices
as well as the the radicals and
militants who prowl our communities
every night
rampaging and pillaging feeling morally
justified all the while because
they're only tearing down a system that
murders innocent black people in droves
this is the conspiracy theory that burns
our cities
and tears our country apart and
threatens to damage us
in ways that i fear cannot be undone
so if you're worried about dangerous
conspiracy theories
this is the one you should be focused on
debunking we get to our five headlines
[Music]
look at anyone who runs a business can
tell you more than i can they know
better than i do that
when you're running a business one of
the most important things to have
together have squared away
is your hr team because hr issues
in a business context can absolutely
kill you
wrongful termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations
um all the red tape that you got to know
how to navigate and uh and it's
difficult you know because not
as a business owner you can't you can't
know everything you can't be
uh omniscient as as as as so often it
feels like probably you have to be
um an hr manager salaries aren't cheap
you know an average of seventy thousand
dollars a year
but that's where bambi comes in bambi
spelled b-a-m-b-e-e
was created specifically to solve this
problem for small businesses you can get
a dedicated hr manager can craft hr
policy maintain your compliance all for
just 99
a month so decide if you want 75 or 70
000
a year or 99 a month which which would
you rather spend i think it's pretty
i'm not good at math but even i could do
the math there with bambi you can change
hr from your biggest liability to your
biggest strength your dedicated hr
manager is available by phone email
real-time chat uh and this is all month
to month so there's no hidden fees you
can cancel any time
so you're not getting locked into
something uh but yeah
i think once you once you get started
with bambi you're not going to want to
to leave
you know you didn't start your business
because you wanted to spend time on hr
compliance i don't think that's anyone's
dream when they start a business
um that's why you need bambi go to
bambeed.com
walsh right now to schedule your free hr
audit that's bambi.com
walsh spelled b-a-m-b-e-e
dot com slash walsh well the
insurrectionist says we've been
discussing or
swarming our cities across the country
again last night
i could probably stop saying that you
could just assume that they're out there
every night being scumbags doing what
scumbags do but this incident in la
is above and beyond much of what we've
seen so far
so let's first watch the video and then
i'll describe it for those listening on
the audio podcast but
watch it right now okay so you have
there a driver trying to drive around
the rioters
who are in the middle of the street now
yes
they think we've seen this all across
the country they think that
they have the right to shut down any
street they want to
you know direct traffic they can do
whatever they want
um and if you try to it's not just it's
not if you
if you run them over if you try to just
go around them
to go down a street that they don't want
you on for whatever reason
then they think now they have every
right to uh
smash your windows assault you pull you
out of the car kill you if that's what
they decide to do
so in this case you got a driver trying
to go around the rioters
they swarm his car he successfully
escapes doesn't doesn't hit anybody
is driving away on an empty street okay
it's not like he's plowing through
like a bowling ball going through
rioters no he's going down an empty
street
and then what do they do they get into
cars and they chase him
in vehicles cut him off attack the
vehicle
and then and try to pull him out and
finally at the end we see cops show up
and arrest
him the victim so
two points here the first is that
just again these protesters are monsters
they are evil they'll they're soulless
dirt bags
the divide between good guy and bad guy
in this
situation is so clear we have rarely
seen in america a political movement
that was so thoroughly and obviously
evil
with no redeeming qualities whatsoever
blm and antifa
we're talking about one of the most evil
political movements in american history
utterly destructive violent and hateful
attacking innocent people at random
for no good reason not that it could be
a good reason but they certainly don't
have one
also pathologically dishonest they lie
about everything
their whole movement as we've already
discussed is based on
total lies and fabrications so they're a
lot like the pro-abortion movement in
that way
and there's a lot of crossover there too
i imagine and the pro-abortion movement
is is one of the one of the other
most evil movements in american history
so
that's one point second point is that
the police
i think should be really careful about
alienating the people who are on their
side
you see videos like that you know if
you're a police officer
as i'm sure you've noticed you don't
have a lot of friends
and it's probably not a good idea to
alienate the few friends you do have
but that's what's going to happen when
we see law abiding innocent
victims getting arrested like that
and there are others speaking of
alienating the good guys
um let's uh maybe you've seen this video
from a couple days ago
here's a a christian being arrested
and i believe this is in idaho for
gathering to sing
uh and and praise and worship watch
in this but we recall the lord of god
some past our own resources
our enemies have fallen low
but we are
trouble calling
[Music]
you guys should not be doing this and
doing this kind of crap for the mayor
this is embarrassing
yeah there was also a video that's been
circulating of a woman being tased and
arrested and cuffed
for what for sitting without a mask on a
you know mostly empty
bleachers at a football game this is the
kind of thing that's going to alienate
the
you know the people that are on your
side the good guys going to alienate
them
with this sort of nonsense number two uh
i love this from charles barkley listen
to this
you know i hear these fools on tv
talking about define the police and
things like that
we need police reform and prison reform
and things like that
because you know who ain't gonna defund
the cops
white neighborhoods and rich
neighborhoods so
that notion they keep saying that i'm
like wait a minute we just gonna leave
who are black people supposed to call
ghostbusters when we have crime in our
neighborhoods
we need police reform but like i say
white people
especially rich white people they're
always going to have cops so we need to
stop that
defund or abolish the cops crap yeah
just basic common sense there
um and what does it tell you that
at this point when somebody is on tv
saying just basic common sense stuff
all he's really saying is no of course
we don't want to get rid of the police
department are you kidding me
and of course if you're in a
neighborhood that's got more crime
then that's all the more reason why you
want police officers
very basic common sense but what does it
say i appreciate him saying it i don't
mean to
dismiss it or belittle it because it is
important to say but what does it say
about our culture that
someone just making a basic common sense
statement like that is
is such a relief and you are so overcome
with joy just to hear it
you know it's like it's like a just a
fresh cup of water when you've been
wandering in a desert that's what it
feels like
a little cup of water a little cup of
sanity amid the uh
desert of madness so good job
from charles barkley there number three
a few days ago speaking of
we'll get back into the madness part of
it now a guy who goes by the name
dreadhead cowboy an activist in chicago
he's worked with mayor
whitefoot uh over there in chicago and
is well known for that locally and he
decided to call attention to
the issues by riding a horse down the
highway
in the middle of traffic so here's some
of that you can see you can see him
riding there
all the cops were trailing well now the
dreadhead cowboy is very shocked and
appalled and victimized because
he got arrested for that stunt shocker
of shockers
actually it is kind of a shock that they
arrested someone in chicago for breaking
the law so i appreciate that
but the main charge is animal cruelty um
the animal was ridden almost to death
might still be euthanized it's in
critical condition right now he he rode
the animal seven miles on the pavement
without proper equipment
nearly killed it in the process all in
the name of activism
but here he is now of course as we know
who who's the real victim here
you block traffic rode a horse almost to
death who's the real victim
well it's him and here he is explaining
that and defending his actions in a
press conference listen
my first time ever i'm just gonna go
into i'm an animal lover period like
all my life i always got an animal lover
and four years ago
it was my first hand ever been around a
horse
and two years later my first chance
owning a horse and i fell in love with
horses since then
and i don't own up to nine horses and
when i say
it's a beautiful thing to own a horse
and i couldn't even tell y'all
the people that don't know anything
about horses from looking for the
outside end
you would think that what i did was
cruelty to animals
but if you go to the racetrack you
work a hundred times worse if you go to
the turkish
worse and get what
like it's way worse than what i do to my
heart and i probably could have did a
little bit last but
i had to make a statement they've done
worse at the circus
that's that that's his defense that may
be one of the worst criminal defenses
i've ever heard in my life
they've done worse at the circus
uh maybe if he gets arrested for murder
he can say hey come on you know they
they did worse in the roman coliseum
haven't you seen gladiator come on guys
give me a break
we'll see if that works out for him it
is chicago so maybe it will number four
another one for the get your kids the
hell out of the public schools
file here's the report from the daily
wire it says earlier this summer the
fairfax county public school system
in virginia paid twenty thousand dollars
to host author ibram kendy for a virtual
event on anti-racism
the left-wing ideology whose adherents
believe it is impossible to
not be racist it's impossible to not be
racist yet they hold seminars on how to
not be racist
according to a copy of the contract a
link to the uh to which was included by
journalist azra nomani the school
district paid twenty thousand dollars to
the penguin random house speakers bureau
for a 45-minute virtual event with candy
followed by a 15-minute q
a session school released a statement
defending it
saying that um he's a leading
anti-racist voice in america
blah blah blah et cetera 20 grand for
one hour
online didn't even have to leave his
house
now i admit i i i am a little salty as
the kids would say i i've done some
virtual events during this pandemic
um and i i've been paid for a few of
them i can tell you that
i don't get paid anything close to 20
000 for a virtual event actually it
never even occurred to me to ask for
that kind of money
to sit when you don't have to leave your
house
like here's really the scale if i don't
even have to put on
pants to do the event then i feel like i
can't ask for that kind of money
that's the scale if i have to put on
pants there's going to be an extra
there's going to be charges and fees
that are attached to that and i'll put
that on the invoice of putting on the
pants fee
but when you're just skyping from your
house 20 grand my god
now i ask you to consider this though
reflect on this
is a country oppressing black people
when a black man can get twenty thousand
dollars
to talk about how oppressed he is what
do you think
think about historical examples think
about a you know other oppressive
countries
nazi germany the left often compares the
two
uh could people who were oppressed in
nazi germany make thousands of dollars
talking about that oppression
i don't think so it almost seems like
if you can get paid a lot if you can
make a lot of money in a certain country
going around talking about how bad the
country is to you and how you're pressed
pretty good indication you're not
oppressed at all in fact the country is
very kind to you and again
you're doing very well in the country uh
i don't know
maybe i'm crazy number five finally
important psa for you a black licorice
fans out there
a massachusetts man died last year from
eating an excessive amount of black
licorice
doctors said on wednesday the unusual
case was reported in the new england
journal of medicine
detailing how the man consumed a bag and
a half of the candy this is from the new
york post by the way i'm reading
a bag of half of the candy every day for
two weeks prior to his death
licorice contains uh certain
acids and things which can deplete
potassium levels and contribute to heart
rhythm problems
according to doctors so he collapsed
inside a fast food restaurant died the
next day
very sad of course um i will say though
that i i recently discovered that black
licorice is good
um i i and i a lot of people are biased
against black licorice i i think the the
bias
is is mostly because people and this is
a big problem with food in general
you have your first experience with
black licorice when you're in
childhood right and um when your palate
is unrefined
and you hate anything that isn't sickly
sweet
think about when you're a kid you could
eat like pixie stix
in fact i don't even know if they sell
these anymore probably with all the
public health people out there
they can't but i when i was a kid they
used to sell these
massive like garden hose sized
pixie sticks just full of sugar and so
you would just take the
garden hose of of sugar and spray it
directly in your mouth
and i enjoyed that now now i couldn't do
that without vomiting
that's because as your kid your palate
isn't quite developed and you can't you
can't deal with more nuanced
complex flavors and so you try black
licorice you don't like it brussels
sprouts another one
olives liver you got to go back around
as an adult
and discover that these things are
actually good although apparently
uh they can kill you within two weeks so
that's the downside
all right um let me get to our daily
cancellation just one second but as part
of our daily wire audience you know
there are a number of ways to take in
this podcast you may listen on apple
podcast spotify another podcast app
you can watch on youtube uh facebook
over at daily wire bottom line there are
a ton of ways to to
you know enjoy this content but daily
wire members can also now enjoy our
shows on apple tv and roku so members
can
see all the visual elements of the
podcast on on and our other shows as
well
on your big screen either live or on
demand find the daily wire on apple tv
or roku
and and download today you have to be an
inside member
to watch live so head over to
delhiwire.com walsh and use
code watch at checkout to get 15 off
your membership purchase
the deal is not going to last forever so
make sure you go
dailywire.com walsh
15 off with codewatch and you can
download the daily wire on your apple tv
and roku
today today for our daily cancellation
something special here
a little different you know normally
here i cancel someone
that's why i call it the daily
cancellation but today
what i really like to do is flip it
around and rather than canceling
i'm going to defend someone from
cancellation this is more of an
anti-cancellation today i think it's
important sometimes to come out
to the defense of those who are unjustly
accused unjustly canceled
and frankly it's the right thing to do
simple as that i believe in doing the
right thing
so today um the person i'd like to
defend from cancellation is someone who
is for my money
one of our greatest living americans um
a man of
virtue and generosity who is unfairly
maligned and does not
deserve any of the negative treatment
this person receives and i refer of
course
to myself i am the one who is being
unjustly canceled and worst of all it's
my wife
trying to do it to me honestly i can't
believe that my own spouse would try to
cancel me
in public that is something i would
never do to her but again this is how
it usually goes in my life i find that i
am so often the victim while everyone
else so often is wrong
it's the burden i carry now my wife last
week put me on blast
as the kids say or did say in 2003
anyway
this is what she tweeted she says
hypothetically
what would you do if your spouse forgot
your anniversary
clearly hypothetical situation that
would never happen right
matt walsh yes if you can believe it she
is
insinuating accusing me of
forgetting our anniversary this is a
libelous charge
and she also has her facts completely
wrong she says i forgot the anniversary
even though our anniversary hasn't
happened yet
doesn't happen until late october or
maybe november
definitely sometime in there anyway the
point is i cannot
have forgotten that which has not
occurred the reason she accuses me of
this is simply that i may have
hypothetically allegedly
scheduled something for the same day as
our anniversary something work-related
which i may not be able to cancel or
change at this point
i may have done that because i may not
have realized at the time of the
scheduling that it was our anniversary
i may have mentioned in passing to my
wife so
i may have said oh hey i got this thing
coming up and she may have said
you know that's our anniversary right
and i may have responded
oh sh but does this count as forgetting
an anniversary
well only in the sense that anyone in
the world can be accused of forgetting
anything
now here's the argument i presented to
my wife i came with facts and logic
she simply couldn't handle it but here
are the facts
miriam webster defines forgets as quote
to lose the remembrance of
to cease remembering or noticing
dictionary.com adds this
to fail to think of take no note of
okay so you're forgetting something if
you're ceasing to notice failing to
think of
failing to take note of well in that
sense as i explained to my wife with
devastating logic in that sense everyone
forgets
all future events because unless you're
presently thinking of a certain future
event at every moment of every day
you're guilty of forgetting it for
example did you wake up this morning
thinking about your own birthday
three years from now well then you
forgot your own birthday in that moment
are you at this present moment thinking
about thanksgiving coming up well you
are now because i mentioned it but
before that
you forgot it so you see i forgot the
the anniversary a future event only in
the same sense that
all people forget everything and indeed
the same sense that she herself forgets
everything including
the very anniversary that she's accusing
me of forgetting
i laid out this case to her and and she
cut me off and said and i quote
matt stop but that is not an argument
that's an attempt at censorship an
assault on free speech
the fact remains that my argument is
reasonable and fact based and i haven't
even gotten into the fact yet that
time is relative and we base
anniversaries on the earth's orbit of
the sun which is arbitrary in any case
if we lived on pluto we'd still be 239
years away from our first anniversary
our first anniversary we'd have no
anniversaries if we lived on pluto think
about that so in conclusion
i am not canceled i am an innocent man
falsely accused
i will not fall silent in the face of
these attacks and my wife i trust will
come in time to appreciate
both the sound logic of my position and
the inspiring bravery required to defend
it
you might even say that through this
example i'm providing
i am providing an anniversary gift in a
certain way
yes that's good i think that works
so i am not canceled today
and that's going to do it for us today
and this week
i hope you have a great weekend
mine might be a little dicey to be
honest with you but that's all right
godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20. if you prefer facts over feelings
aren't offended by the brutal truth and
you can still laugh at the insanity
filling our national news cycle well
tune in to the ben shapiro show we'll
get a whole lot of that
and much more see you there